Speaker 1: We have not spoken about George
Anthony Devil there, Santos, the lying Republican
congressman, for some period of time. But there
are even more new scandals related to Santos. I
do think it would be great for him to resign. It
would be better even for him to be forced out.
But it is not at all apparent that there is an
interest among the Republican Party in doing that.
George Santos has actually filed for reelection,
although it is considered more of a technical
thing than any real desire to actually run in 2024
in order to keep his I believe it's his campaign
fund going, or there was some sort of technical
finance reason why he did that. Let's start with
the first story. George Santos is now accused of
orchestrating a credit card skimming operation,
credit card skimming operation which schemed
to steal information from ATM and credit cards.
This is according to a sworn statement from a
former roommate of his obtained by Politico,
the declaration from this man who said he met
Santos when he rented a room in Florida from
the now congressman states he was accused of a
federal crime of credit card fraud in 2017 and
pleaded guilty. The man, Treloar, who is from
Brazil, served seven months in prison and was
then deported. His attorney sent the letter to
the FBI, U.S. Attorney's Office for the Eastern
District of New York and Secret Service in New
York on Wednesday. Trellis said Santos was known
to him as Anthony Deveaux, older, another name
tied to Santos. He added that he learned from
Santos how to clone ATM and credit cards after he
started renting the room from him. Quote Santos
taught me how to skim card information and how
to clone cards. He gave me all the material and
taught me how to put skimming devices and cameras
on ATM machines, he said. Santos had a warehouse
in Orlando, Florida. This is if this is true,
this is a professional criminal. I really want
people to understand that this is a professional
criminal. If this is true. Santos had a warehouse
in Orlando that housed materials such as printers,
blank ATM, and credit cards that could be painted
and engraved with stolen account and personal
information. The way this kind of works and
sometimes you hear there's these, like, scarce
things about this, but this stuff does exist.
You can put a device on top of an ATM. This rarely
would happen if you go to like a Wells Fargo ATM
in, you know, you have to swipe your use your
ATM card just to even get in and all that. It's
unlikely this would happen there, but I'm sure
many of you are familiar with these kind of like
lower end ATMs where you might go to like a cash
only dive bar and they go cash only and you're
like, I don't have any cash. And they go ATM right
there. Those types of ATMs in the corner of a bar,
for example, and others are the more likely
ATMs to be targeted by this sort of thing.
And sometimes what happens is they put a device on
top of where you would insert or swipe your card.
And when you do that, it gathers the information
and then you type in your pin and there might be
a camera where they take it. They see you typing
the pin or maybe the device itself, that there's
different versions of this, but it's usually those
types of independent ATMs in general at a mall,
potentially, etc.. I've at least not heard
of it happening like at a bank atm. Anyway,
the idea here is that he was installing these
things. Trello said he went to Seattle, began to
steal credit card information from ATM terminals
with the deal that the profits would be split
between he and Santos. He decried that Santos
threatened his friends after he was arrested to
not tell authorities that Santos was actually the
one in charge. Troller claimed Santos stole the
money he collected for his bail. He said he has
other witnesses who can back it all up. This is
a sworn statement. A sworn statement. So this
is the latest scandal involving George Anthony
Duvall there. Santos This is not surprising,
like he's a lying fraudster in many ways. And so
committing actual criminal fraud would not come
as a surprise to me at all. There seems to be
something kind of compulsive about it. Compulsive
lying is when you just you you just make up lies
on the spot. It's not even clear why you're lying
about this stuff. And it seems as though he may
have some kind of compulsion to fraud and
criminality of different kinds. He's really
the epitome of the MAGA candidate, Right? Make
America grift again. Just a liar and a fraudster
all the way through. As a reminder, how can a
sitting member of the House be removed? There
aren't too many ways either. The House of
Representative votes to expel him with a two
thirds vote. Very, very rare. Usually only when
there is like conviction on criminal activity
and then failure to be reelected, which you can't
really take action on until 2024. So that's where
we are right now on Santos. And it doesn't
end there. I'm going to be honest with you.